Beyoncé rompe un nuevo récord
Es un honor porque estamos presenciando
un momento histórico esta noche con el
récord de la mayoría de los premios
Grammy durante la edición número 65 de
los premios Grammy la cantante tejana se
convirtió en la artista más galardonada
en la historia acumulando 32 gramófonos
dorados y destronando al director de
Orquesta George quien tenía el récord de
31 estatuillas
me gustaría agradecer a mi hermoso
esposo mis hermosos tres hijos que están
en casa mirándome
[Aplausos]
me gustaría agradecer a la comunidad
queer por su amor y por inventar el
género Dios los bendiga Muchas gracias a
Los Grammys gracias
Beyoncé llegó a la ceremonia con nueve
nominaciones y logró su récord gracias
al álbum
renacence por mejor álbum Dance
electrónica la ex integrante de design
Child se convirtió en la primera mujer
con más nominaciones en la historia de
los premios al alcanzar un total de 88
menciones un hito que comparte con su
esposo jaycee Beyoncé tiene una lista de
hazañas en las ediciones anteriores en
Los Grammys en 2009 fue nominada en 10
categorías diferentes además de ser la
cantante que ha recibido más
nominaciones a grabación del año
chica latina dime qué fue
los premios más importantes de la
industria musical anglosajona comenzaron
hablando español El puertorriqueño Bad
Bunny interpretó el apagón en el arena
cripto.com de Los Ángeles el Grammy más
codiciado disco del año fue para Harry
Styles por Harry House catalogándolo
como un fenómeno musical
he estado tan tan inspirado por cada
artista en esta categoría conmigo en
muchos momentos de mi vida escuchaba a
todos en esta categoría cuando estaba
solo
artistas como Adele liso Sam Smith y
Rosalía también fueron galardonados
mientras que la organización honra del
aniversario número 50 del hip hop con
los artistas más importantes del género
[Aplausos]